yesterday as we were waiting for the
results from the Roy Moore Doug Jones
Alabama special Senate election which
ultimately Doug Jones won defeating the
alleged serial child sex assault or Roy
Moore all sorts of interviews were
happening on television with campaign
surrogates and one of these surrogates
is Roy Moore spokesman Ted Crockett
you're gonna like Ted I think Roy Moore
has previously said that he doesn't
believe Muslims should be allowed in
Congress now that's an obviously
unconstitutional position from a guy who
claims to be all about the Constitution
but that's not at hand that's not the
subject of today's discussion this guy
Ted Crockett goes on CNN Jake Tapper
interviews him and asks him perfectly
reasonable question he's the spokesman
explained to us why Roy Moore doesn't
believe Muslims should be allowed to
serve in Congress and the spokesman says
we'll listen you got a swear on a
Christian Bible to be in Congress and if
you're Muslim you're not going to be
able to believably swear an oath of
office on a Christian Bible and Jake
Tapper explains to him no you choose
what you swear an oath on you can choose
a Christian Bible or a Hebrew Bible or a
Quran or nothing at all it doesn't
really matter and Roy Moore spokesman
seems so stunned so taken aback that he
went totally silent now if you're
listening to this and not watching you
might think Oh David you extended the
silence to make it seem like it was
longer than it really was
no no no we are going to play this clip
for you as it appeared originally on CNN
the silence has not been extended it is
it's full cringe-worthy reality take a
listen to this Judge Moore has also said
that he doesn't think a Muslim member of
Congress should be allowed to be in
Congress why under what under what
because you have to swear on the Bible
you and you when you are before I had to
do it I'm an elected official three
terms I had to swear on a Bible you have
to swear on a Bible to be an elected
official in the United States of America
Haley
is that a Muslim cannot do that
ethically swearing on the Bible you
don't actually have to swear on a
Christian Bible you can swear on
anything really I don't know if you knew
that you can swear on Jewish Bible Oh No
the Bible I've done it three times I'm
sure you have I'm sure you've picked a
Bible but the law is not that you have
to swear on a Christian Bible that is a
not the law you did you don't know that
all right Ted Crockett well I don't know
I know that Donald Trump did it when he
when we made him present because he's
Christian and he picked it that's what
he wanted to that's we wanted to swear
in on Ted Crockett with the more
campaign good luck tonight thank you so
much for being here my panel will react
thank you sir I love at the end telling
Jewish Jake Tapper Merry Christmas just
like every detail about is this perfect
well Trump did it he swore on a Bible
the guy's mouth was hanging open and he
was doing this slow blink which makes it
his brain seemed to malfunction right
how could it be a choice to swear on a
Christian Bible it seems just impossible
this is possibly the dumbest and most
confused I've ever seen a member of Homo
sapiens look in the history of
television and the endless number of
hours of political interviews that I've
ever watched I used to just think that
these people wanted the u.s. to be a
Christian theocracy they don't actually
think it is and that no wonder why they
want the Ten Commandments to be in court
house yeah if you believe that everyone
has to swear on a Christian Bible to be
an elected member of office why wouldn't
you think it's fine for the Ten
Commandments to be on public property
quite literally confirmation dot bias
and fallacy by example he's only ever
seen people swear on Christian Bibles so
you must be legally required to do that
just so embarrassing really shocking and
the problem is that this is like playing
chess with your dog right it doesn't
matter how obviously you win the dog is
not gonna notice and that's probably
what a lot of people who supported Roy
Moore would react to when they how they
would react when they see this which is
what's the big deal yeah you should be
swearing on a Christian you really
thought that he had the winning argument
here he really did hey a Trump sawr on
it I swore on it unbelievable and
the guy that was represented that this
person represents Roy Moore he almost
won right so we are just only by the
tiniest bit out of the woods send me
your thoughts about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show today's program is sponsored
in part by movement watches I have been
a user a wearer of movement watches for
a while now I really like my movement
watch and I think that these make really
great gifts and for me it's sort of a
double incentive number one I hate
giving people weird kitchen gadgets that
they'll never use or some piece of
clothing that will end up being used to
mop up the remains of some dinner gone
awry I would actually like to give
people something that they would use and
I also hate spending time at shopping
malls and department stores and parking
and driving and getting through crowds
of people to buy gifts so I like the
idea of going to MVM t-dot-com slash
Pakman saving 15% off of a great-looking
watch men's Styles women's styles and
spending as little as 95 dollars instead
of the 4 or $500 that you would pay for
a similar watch in a department store
these make really great gifts
why wait and the horrible experience of
shopping for holiday gifts in crowded
malls and stores get 15% off free
shipping free returns at MVM t.com /pa
km am